as fun as it is to watch a great movie
there's no guarantee that you'll walk
out of the theater feeling good yourself
here are a few fantastic flicks where
the last few minutes are so monumentally
depressing that they're almost
guaranteed to ring a few tears from the
audience
if you only saw the last three minutes
of End of Watch you might think this cop
drama was ending on a happy note the
final scene features two buddies having
a laugh over a crazy story on what looks
like a pretty good day unfortunately
context is everything in actuality the
camaraderie between officers Brian
Taylor and Mike Savala is an incredibly
Bittersweet flashback scene one that
jumps back to a moment before Zavala was
gunned down by gangsters Taylor and
Zavala are super cops in fact they're
such good cops that they try to take
down the Sinaloa cartel only that
doesn't pan out too well after
disrupting the cartel's business the
officers are ambushed by heavily armed
Thugs and despite their bravery Taylor
is Gravely injured and Zavala is
murdered after learning about his
partner's death Taylor is absolutely
shattered Zavala was his best friend in
the world and at the funeral Taylor is
so grief stricken that he can only
muster four powerful words that make all
those happy moments heartbreaking he was
my brother
despite their god-like superpowers The
Avengers are a sad bunch of people and
the most tragic might just be Steve
Rogers a man out of time in Captain
America the First Avenger the
Star-Spangled superhero decides to
sacrifice his life crashing a hydroplane
into the Arctic Ice
in those final moments before taking the
plunge cap promises to take his new love
Peggy Carter dancing as soon as he
returns obviously neither expects Steve
to make it back home but well you've
seen the movies
I understood that reference
when cap finally returns he learns that
he's been asleep for nearly seven
decades it's a gut punch of a moment and
the look of shock and sadness on Cap's
face is heartbreaking yeah he survived
the suicide mission but the world he
knew is gone and he's been separated
from the woman he loves for most of a
century when Fury finally asks if cap is
going to be okay all his pain is summed
up in one sentence yeah yeah I just
thank you
I had a date war movies aren't really
known for their upbeat endings but when
it comes to Pure tear-jerking power
nothing goes after your heartstrings
like 1989's Glory this Civil War flick
tells the story of the 54th
Massachusetts Infantry which was the
first African-American regiment to fight
for the Union Army the regiment was led
by Colonel Robert Shaw played in the
film by Matthew Broderick and after
overcoming all the racism you'd expect
from the 1860s Shaw and the 54th wind up
leading the charge in the film's
climactic battle unfortunately that
battle doesn't go their way after being
surrounded by Confederate soldiers Shaw
charges the enemy hoping to inspire his
men and he's quickly gunned down enraged
private Silas trip a role that earned
Denzel Washington an Academy Award picks
up the flag and charges after the
colonel only to be shot down seconds
later their sacrifice inspires the rest
of the 54th to rush out of the Ravine
and continue their charge but despite
their bravery the historic soldiers are
no match for cannonballs and all the
characters We've Come To Love played by
the likes of Morgan Freeman Carrie elwis
and Andre Brauer are blown to Oblivion
if that wasn't sad enough the movie ends
with Shaws and Tripps bodies being
buried side by side in a mass grave
Gone Baby Gone isn't exactly a feel-good
film to begin with and the ending is
appropriately downbeat based on the
novel by Dennis lehane this thriller
follows two Boston detectives Patrick
Kenzie and Angie Gennaro who are hired
to find a little girl named Amanda at
first they believed this kid was
murdered by a local drug dealer but as
they dig deeper into the case they
discover a surprising conspiracy as it
turns out Amanda's concerned Uncle
kidnapped her from her abusive addict
mother with the help of several
high-ranking cops but Patrick isn't a
big believer in moral ambiguity and
brings the conspiracy down and has the
little girl sent back home you may not
regret it when you get home
you may not regret it for a year but
when they get to where I am I promise
you
you will sure enough it doesn't take
long for regret to set in when Patrick
goes to visit Amanda he sees that her
mom is just as awful as ever and
realizes he might have damned Amanda to
a life of poverty neglect and
mistreatment in the final moments he
volunteers to babysit Amanda and sits
beside her watching the traumatized
lonely girl as she stares at the
television
it might seem weird to say this about a
movie where a gorilla fights a
helicopter but Rise of the Planet of the
Apes has more than its fair share of
emotional moments nothing can top the
finale when Caesar aptly played by mocap
Master Andy Circus says goodbye to his
human friend will Rodman their
relationship is the emotional Crux of
the story Caesar has known well his
entire life and the biologist is
basically his adoptive dad in fact will
is the guy who gave Caesar his above
average intelligence but after will is
forced to put Caesar in a Primate
Sanctuary the chimpanzee decides it's
time for a revolution after sparking a
full-blown primate rebellion and a
battle on the Golden Gate Bridge Caesar
and his army disappear into a redwood
forest but before Vanishing into the
trees Caesar is confronted by Will who
begs the chimp to come back home that's
when Caesar pulls his foster father
close and Whispers in his ear
oh
with those three powerful words Caesar
and will realize nothing will ever be
the same
Tom Hanks movies generally leave
audiences feeling pretty good but Road
to Perdition is a bloody exception to
that cheerful rule this gangster flick
finds Hank's playing Michael Sullivan
senior a mob enforcer out for Revenge
while trying to make sure his surviving
son Michael Jr doesn't wind up dead too
that's easier said than done when you're
being hunted by a psychopathic Hitman
for a moment it seems like everything
might be okay then Michael's violent
past catches up with him when he's
ambushed by the Assassin after taking
two bullets in the back Michael lies
dying as the psychopathic Hitman
assembles an old-timey camera and begins
taking photos of his bloody victim
Michael Jr shows up with a gun to
interrupt the hitman's sick hobby but
unlike his dad the boy isn't a killer
fortunately the distraction gives his
father enough time to gun down the
Assassin before shuffling off this
Mortal coil what really seals the deal
and cues the sobbing though is Michael
Jr's final lines answering the question
of whether his father was a good man
I always give the same answer
I just tell them
he was my father directed by Martin
Scorsese Shutter Island is a frightening
film Noir that finds Leonardo DiCaprio
as Teddy Daniels a detective who's
investigating a disappearance on an
alcatraz-style mental hospital but as
Teddy and his partner dig deeper into
the case Teddy makes a horrible
Discovery he isn't really Teddy in
reality he's Andrew ladies a World War
II vet who killed his mentally ill wife
after she murdered their kids his
partner is actually his psychologist and
the whole investigation is an elaborate
role-playing game meant to bring Andrew
back to reality and if the game doesn't
work then poor Andrew has to get
lobotomized after this shocking twist it
seems that Andrew reverts back to his
Teddy Persona forcing his doctors to
perform the lobotomy but before he's
taken away to his mind-numbing fate
Teddy looks over at Chuck and asks a
haunting question
which would be worse
Liv is a monster
I want to die is a good man it's a
simple line but it conveys the crushing
sadness of Andrew's story The Experiment
worked Andrew knows exactly who he is
and what he's done it's his guilt that
leads him to accept his grisly fate
Arnold Schwarzenegger movies aren't
generally considered tear-jerkers but
the ending of Terminator 2 Judgment Day
has caused so many sobs from Macho movie
fans that it's basically the action
movie equivalent of the notebook you
think I'm an emotional don't you I can
be emotional Jesus I cried like a child
at the end of Terminator 2 sent from the
future to protect teenage John Connor
the T800 starts out this sci-fi flick as
an ice cold killer robot as he spends
time with a future resistance leader
however the T800 becomes the teen's best
friend and Father Figure growing
increasingly lovable as he battles with
a shape-shifting Android he's picking up
slang words developing human emotions
and learning you can't just go around
killing people he also realizes that if
humanity is going to survive then all
Terminators need to be destroyed after
defeating the T-1000 Arnold realizes
that if he doesn't destroy the advanced
AI inside his own head that Tech will
eventually give rise to the robot
Rebellion that will Doom mankind so
despite Jon's pleas for him to stay the
team 800 slowly lowers himself into a
pit of molten steel he gives a thumbs up
before disintegrating completely letting
John know everything is going to be okay
but despite that reassurance poor John
is in tears man so is everybody watching
the saddest ending in Schwarzenegger's
career
I know now why you cry
I think I can never do
with movies like Requiem for a Dream in
his filmography it's safe to say that
Darren Aronofsky loves a truly
depressing ending but of all the films
he's ever directed none have caused as
much sobbing as the wrestler this gritty
and Grim drama follows the story of
Randy the Ram Robinson a professional
wrestler who's far from his in-ring
Glory Days this dude has lived a hard
life and made some bad decisions and now
he's all alone his daughter doesn't want
anything to do with him his romantic
life isn't working out and the world
outside the ring is nothing but pain and
misery lonely and depressed Randy gets
back into the wrestling game where at
least the fans respect and adore him but
stepping back into the ring comes at a
high price Randy has a bad heart and
knows that another match might be his
last however when he hears the cheers of
the crowd the wrestler climbs up onto
the turnbuckle to perform his signature
move even as his heart starts to fail
him when he leaps down onto his opponent
we know it's the last time he'll ever do
the legendary Ram Jam but it's all worth
it for Randy because he's living and
dying for the only family he's ever
known the fans who now have to watch
their hero die in the ring in front of
them Man on Fire may not have been a
favorite of critics but Denzel
Washington's performance as alcoholic
bodyguard John Gracie was one of the
most moving of his career after years of
boost and bullets crazy gets a shot at
Redemption as a bodyguard for Peter
played by Dakota Fanning when a powerful
crime syndicate captures Peter Gracie
buys pretty much every gun in Mexico and
goes on a murder spree eventually
capturing the kidnapper's brother dying
from a gunshot wound crazy trades
himself for the safety of his charge but
before handing himself over he reunites
with Peter for just a few seconds when
he tells her goodbye it's a moment that
will make even the toughest action fan
weep
where are you going
[Music]
I'm going home too
while the boxing drama Million Dollar
Baby May at times feel as inspirational
as Rocky Rocky Balboa never ended a
movie quite like this Hillary Swank
plays Maggie Fitzgerald a backwards
waitress hoping to make her name as a
boxer and director Clint Eastwood plays
grizzled trainer Frankie Dunn Dunn is
reluctant to teach a woman at first
especially one as old as Maggie but
eventually her persistence wins him over
Maggie proves her worth koing away to a
championship fight and that's when the
movie takes a hard left turn Maggie is
paralyzed from the neck down when her
opponent illegally punches her after the
Bell a hero Falls hard from the punch
smashing her neck against a footstool
Maggie loses her leg and she begs her
trainer to end her suffering Dunn
refuses at first but agrees after Maggie
tries and fails to commit suicide before
Dunn administers the lethal injection he
tells Maggie the meaning of the Irish
nickname
kushler
means my darling
my blood even Steely eyed Eastwood can't
keep the tears back here and you know if
even Dirty Harry is getting weepy
there's no way you're going to be able
to hold it back
Niagara Falls Frankie Angel
after the tragic death of bear
Enthusiast Timothy Treadwell at the jaws
of a brown bear director Werner Herzog
assembled Treadwell's footage and
created Grizzly Man one of the most
moving documentaries of all time Grizzly
Man follows Treadwell as he Journeys
into the Alaskan Wilderness interacts
with animals and shares his unique view
about a man's place in nature while
Treadwell's behavior is sometimes
questionable it's hard not to admire his
passion with the help of hertzog's
guiding hand we grow attached to
Treadwell as Grizzly Man heads for its
inevitable tragic ending while we go
into Grizzly Man knowing Treadwell's
fate It's upsetting to finally say
goodbye to such a unique soul in the
film's last moments we watched for the
last time as tradwell wanders into the
woods accompanied by two Fuzzy Friends
and a mournful country song that feels
like it was written just for him while
Wes Anderson directs comedy there's
always a deep sense of melancholy
underlying his work that's especially
true for the Grand Budapest Hotel set in
the fictional European country of zoo
Grove car The film's Narrative is
nestled inside multiple timelines with
the bulk of it set during the 1930s Our
Hero Zero Mustafa played by both Tony
revelauri and EV Murray Abraham works as
a lobby boy at the Grand Budapest Hotel
under the guidance of flamboyant
concierge M Gustav played by Ray feins
the plot involves a dead heiress a
missing painting and a family of greedy
goons but the drama revolves around the
dark shadow hanging over this dream
world in the 1930s the hotel is an
impossibly Charming world of pastel
colors as the story continues both
zubrovka and Grand Budapest are overrun
by enemy forces quasi-nazis followed by
quasi-soviets as the totalitarian
horrors of the 20th century creep in M
Gus civilized world starts to fade
guests stop coming and eventually the
building is torn down M Gustav is killed
during the war communism washes over
zubrovka and zero is left alone with
nothing but his memories of better days
the film ends with the nostalgic author
saying over the closing frame it was an
enchanting old ruin but I never managed
to see it again on its cold gray surface
the black coats daughter is a movie
about a girl who's demonically possessed
but under the slow building dread in
Eerie music there's a tragic story about
a helpless child afraid of being alone
played it first by Kiernan shipka and
later by Emma Roberts Kat is a boarding
school student with some serious
abandonment issues when her parents are
late to pick her up for the semester
break cat freaks out it doesn't help
matters any when she has an unsettling
dream about her parents untimely fate
terrified her parents are dead and that
she'll be all alone in the world cat
literally makes a deal with devil
allowing herself to be possessed in
exchange for companionship she's so
afraid of losing the spirit's company
she beheads three people at its urge
when a priest exercises the demon from
cat she's so scared of being alone that
she begs the Beast to stay unfortunately
her pleas are no match for holy water
years later an older cat murders two new
victims and brings their heads back to
the school hoping her sacrifice will
summon the demon when she realizes the
evil spirit has left the school behind
the movie ends with cat sobbing and
screaming into the wintry void she
realizes now that she's truly by herself
nobody will ever come to pick her up and
even the devil doesn't want her directed
by Damien chazelle La La Land follows
two star-crossed lovers Emma Stone as
aspiring actress Mia and Jazz devotee
Sebastian played by Ryan Gosling Mia and
Sebastian enjoyed the happiness and
heartache all long-term relationships
face eventually because of their
conflicting Ambitions that go their
separate ways five years later Mia is a
movie star and Sebastian runs a thriving
nightclub one night they lock eyes
across a room and were treated to an
elaborate dream sequence it's the kind
of ending we expect to see the guy and
girl end up with one another and live
happily ever after but the dream soon
comes to an end with Mia and Sebastian
once again going their own ways it's a
heartbreaking reminder that the choices
we make always leave the door open
through a grad before Tony Stark made
his Iron Man suit and before Christian
Bale donned the bat cow there was Hugh
Jackman this Wolverine Jackman played
Logan to Perfection to the point where
it almost seems impossible that any
actor could ever replace him in the role
he defined Wolverine for well over a
decade appearing in every X-Men movie up
until his blood-soaked swan song 2017's
Logan said in the near-distant future
Logan follows a dying Wolverine as he
uses the last of his strength to protect
the young Laura who Logan eventually
learns is actually his clone a shady
scientist wants Laura for nefarious
purposes and he has the vicious
cybernetic reavers under his command at
first Logan is such a broken man that he
wants nothing to do with Laura and only
the Aging Professor X convinces him to
do the right thing unfortunately
Professor X doesn't survive the journey
but Logan continues to help Laura all
the same when Laura and other mutant
children try to escape into Canada
Wolverine makes his final stand in the
woods to protect their escape but even
after fighting all the reavers Logan
still must face a clone made to be a
stronger younger version of himself with
the help of Laura and her allies the
Clone is killed but Logan's wounds are
too much for him thankfully after a
brutal life full of hard decisions Logan
enjoys a moment of father love before
shuffling off this Mortal coil in the
film's final scene a tearful Laura gives
Logan the eulogy he deserves quoting
Alan ludd's final monologue from the
classic Western Shane there's no living
with security there's no going back
right or wrong it's a brand
I pray that sticks after ending a speech
Laura tips the cross on his grave over
on his side marking the Wolverine's
final resting place with an X while the
past few years have given us plenty of
amazing superhero movies Logan was the
first superhero movie to truly make
audiences weep for such an iconic
character since thanos's first MCU
appearance in 2012 Marvel fans couldn't
wait for the big purple Baddie to throw
down with the Avengers the MCU
filmmakers only gave his brief teasing
glimpses of the Mad Titan first a little
bit in the initial Avengers movie then a
lot more in the Guardians of the Galaxy
and later in Avengers Age of Ultron
finally six years after Avengers Thanos
finally arrived with his Infinity
Gauntlet and Earth's Mightiest Heroes
were completely overmatched it looks
like Thor was going to save the day when
he slammed Stormbreaker into the Mad
Titan's chest but as the God of Thunder
quickly learned
you should have gone for the head
[Music]
and just like that with a snap of his
fingers Thanos wiped out half the
population of the universe including the
majority of our beloved Heroes along
with most of the Avengers turning to
dust almost all the Guardians fell
victim to thanos's perch rocket was
there to watch teenage Groot fade away
and to hear his final I am Groot adding
to the sorrow of many fans Guardians of
the Galaxy's writer and director James
Gunn would eventually reveal that
groot's last I am Groot translated into
the word dad for many fans Peter
Parker's death was the most painful to
watch even though he just fought the
toughest villain in the MCU Peter's
still just a kid afraid of fading away
Infinity War may have the darkest ending
of any major Blockbuster ever there's no
moral Victory no feel-good speech for
the First Time The Avengers have truly
lost and it all ends with Thanos
admiring his handiwork smiling as the
sign Rises on a grateful universe
thank you